جوج خباز ممثل كاتب ملحن ومخرج يعني فنان
كامل متكامل من مجاميعه فهذا الرمضان
متصدر وصراحه يعني مثل العاده في كل عمل
بيعملوا ان كان مسرح او مسلسل او حتى فيلم
في رمضان جورج متصدر بدور نار بتحديدا
النار بالنار المسلسل المحقق نجاح واسع
واللي عمل من اولى حلقات وصدى كبير
واصداؤه كل ما لها جالسه بتزيد جوج طالع
بشخصيه عزيز مدرس الموسيقى الانطوائي صاحب
الشخصيه الجدليه والعنصريه بسبب حدث صار
معه في الماضي وبالتالي انعكس على تعاطي
مع الغير وبيشاركوا في البطوله كل من
الفنان عابد فهد والفنانه كاريس بشار
كل لسانك طويل يعني ولا مركبه ابلكيشن كل
ما اعطى واحد قليل الادب لازم يكون متحف
حبيبي مش ملجا للناجحين خطف 87 من اعلى
التعريف اساسا اذا كتبتها بالفرنساوي ورح
تقراوها تارغه خلصت الحرب بيتهم
على اساس قوات رد عربيه
المسلسل عامل حاله كبيره من الجدل بين
الناس والحوارات اللي بتصير بين كريس بشار
اللي هي مريم وبين جورج خباز وعزيز وصورهم
صارت جزء اساسي من البوستات والتغريدات
الجدليه اللي بنشوفها يوميا وبعد كل حلقه
على المنصه
اما الارشادات بدون جورج فماليه المنصات
وعنوانها ابداع واتقان
ومعنى النجم جوج خباز اهلا فيك معنا جورج
والف مبروك نجاح العمل هذا النجاح الكبير
يعني
مساء الخير
استاذي ساره وشكرا كتير شكرا طب احنا
خلينا نبتدي نتكلم من الدور يعني احنا
عرضنا التغريدات الناس كلها بتتكلم في
التغريدات هذه بتقول انك انت لابس الدور
لبس الدور ما هو يعني الدور انت بتبين فيه
هادي بس نحن بنحس طول الوقت انه في غليان
جالس جنب جوا بصير جوا هذا الشخص كيف
الواحد كيف بتحسسنا بهذا الشعور بدون ما
بتكون جالس بتصرخ وبتجري زي المجنون يعني
مدام ساره انا اللي بيغريني باي دور
تمثيلي اني العبوا هو صراعه الداخلي وهذه
الشخصيه عندها صراع داخلي صراع ما بين
انسينيته وما بين شروط حياته هو مرهف
الاحساس هو بيانيس تعزف بيانو ومدرس بيانو
وبنفس الوقت عنده تاريخ حزين هذا التاريخ
الحزين بخليه يصير انطوائي وعنصري وهذا
الشيء انعكس على سلوكه فهذا التناقض ما
بين رواقه كموسيقي وما بين غضبه المشحون
عبر السنين خليني اعمل الشخصيه بهذه
الطريقه بس اليوم لما من اول ما بدا عرض
المسلسل الناس كلها كانت بتقول هذا مسلسل
جريء جريء جريء انصدمنا من حجم الشفافيه
والجراه في الحوار وفي وصف يعني خلينا
نقول اللي هي بتكون زي المناوشات اللي
بتصير بين اللبنانيين والسوريين وحسسنا
انها يعني فعلا واقعيه يعني اللي بيصير في
المشاهد لما قرات السكريبت ما حسيت انه
اوف هذا الكلام جريء ما عمرنا عملنا شيء
قبل كده زي كده
هو صراحه خليني بس صحح التسميه هو صريح
اكثر من انه جريء انه هذا الواقع هو بفرجي
هالمسلسل نماذج من المجتمع وكل نموذج عم
بيقول رايه وطريقته من وجهه نظره بلغه
الناس بلغه الشارع وهيدي حلاوه هذا
المسلسل يعني حان الوقت انه اذا بدنا
نعالج موضوع له بعد انسانه مثل النار
بالنار مثل موضوع النار بالنار موضوع
العنصريه وخلاف شعبين عايشين مع بعضهم
لازم نحكي الامور مثل ما بتنحكى لنقدر
نوصل للنتيجه هلا انا ما بقدر اجاوبك جواب
كامل لانه نكون عم يجتزيئ رساله المسلسل
خلينا ننطر احداث المسلسل وين بتصير وين
بتصير شخصيه عزيز لاقدر احكيك اكثر واكثر
بهذا الموضوع لما نحرق عناصر المفاجاه
اللي بنفس الوقت مثل ما قلت لك العبره
الانسانيه يلي جايه من هالمسلسل لانه انتم
حتى الان يعني صار في كثير جدل على يعني
على الحوارات على الاشياء وصاروا الناس
بيقولوا انه هدول بحاولوا العنصريه
والنعرات وما الى ذلك ولكن انت تحديدا لما
ننتشر مشهد بينك وبين كريس بشار وصارت في
مواجهه حاميه نزلت بوست كان مهم خلينا
نلبس نعرضه على الشاشه حطيت هذا البوست لك
انت وكنيس وهذي لقطه ما ظهرت من المسلسل
اللي كنت بتقول للناس انه استنوا وشكلكم
انه كفوا المسلسل على قولتك يعني كملوا
واستنوا وهنا شكلكم يعني كانكم اصحاب
وكانها بتدلعك يا جورج
هلا انا وكريس كتير كتير اصحاب بالكواليس
حقيقه انا كسبت صديقه وكسبت مش بس يعني
قيمه فنيه قيمه انسانيه بكل ما بالكلمه من
معنى انا اول مره بمثل مع كريسبي مشاهد
اكثريته معها فانا سعيد جدا بهذه الثنائيه
اذا بدك لانه حيات بشار محترفه ممثله من
العيار الثقيل دمها خفيف جدا
متمسكه لعملها شغوفه جدا واحد بيتفرج
عليها وبينعدى منها شغف فانا سعيد جدا
بهذا المكسب وهذه الصداقه وطبعا استاذ عبد
فهد كمان نفس الشيء بس مشاهد قليله معه مع
انه كمان صار في صداقه بيني وبينه كتير
كبيره بالكواليس اكيد عم نفرجي اول شيء
صدقتنا على صعيد شخصي وعم نكب شويه اذا
بدك عم نكب شويه
التساؤلات انه ماذا سيحصل بين هالشخصين
اللي عم يتنافسوا كل الوقت ويتخانقوا كل
الوقت صح لانه الاحداث ماشيه في معين بس
نحن حاسين انا ما بدي احرق على الناس يمكن
حتمشي في اتجاه تاني المهم حنشوف بس انا
بقول للناس يتفرجوا على المسلسل لانه فعلا
يعني عمل صراحه معمول باتقان يعني بس بما
انك يعني ذكرت حتى ما نزيد الجدل جدل يعني
بما انه كمان ذكرت يعني اسماء يعني
الابطال زملائك معك في العمل خليني اول
شيء ابتدي من عند كاريز كنيس انت بتمدح
فيها الان كثير هي كريس قالت قبل ما تبتدي
تمثل معاك انها اول مره حتمثل معك وانا
متخوفه جدا من هذا الموضوع لانه هي شايفه
انك انت يعني جدا فنان ثقيل فكانت خايفه
هل عبرت لك عن هذه المشاعر
والله بالاول لا حقيقه مثل ما قالت مدام
كراسات كان في حاجز صغير بيناتنا انا جدا
معجب بكاريس بشار قبل ما اتعرف عليها وقبل
ما اشتغل معها هيدا المسلسل كان في ترقب
من الطرفين لما نقول خوف ترقب انه انا كيف
هل يا ترى رح بصير في تناغم بيني وبينه او
لا لانه في حقيقه اكتشاف عم تكتشفي حدا
جديد بدك تشتغلي معه مسلسل طويل 30 حلقه
واكثريه المشاهد انت واياها فانا حسيت
بهذا الترقب ولكن ما لبس ان انكسر هذا
الترقب من اول لقاء ومن اول مشهد بيني
وبينها حقيقه حدا محترف جدا
وبتتقمص الحالي وتتقمص تفاصيل الشخصيه
وتتبنى مشاعر وحيله الشخصيه بشكل كتير
فظيع هي رائعه المشاهد اللي يعني خصوصا
انتم بتعملوها مع بعض شيء رائع بس خليني
كمان انقلك لزميلك الفنان الكبير طبعا
عابد فهد وخلينا كمان يمكن نعرض على
الشاشه انه في طبعا جاتك اشاده على دورك
وخ
ان يرفع الحرج عن احلامه بتقديم زبده
المسرحيه في الدراما التلفزيونيه قوي
يمتلك لائحه اشياءه يعدها ويرقص عليها
شخصيه صلبه تضج بالحياه الداخليه وهذه
تحتاج الى عين ترى الاداء بدقه بحيث
تستطيع ان تفرق اداء المسرح عن الاداء في
التلفزيون طبعا هو هنا بيمدحك لكن رجع جاء
رد من الاستاذ عابد فهد النجم الكبير قال
خلاص بقى حاجه تنظير يلتهب حاله كلياتنا
بدنا نشتغل مني وجر ما في حدا كامل انا
يوم بعمل مشهد رائع ويوم مشهد عادي ويوم
اقل من عادي نحن بظروف بتشبع حق للتجارب
فكره العمل جيده الاخراج جيد التمثيل ماشي
حاله شكرا لكل النقاد والصحفيين
والمتابعين كثير ناس اخذوا هذه التغريده
وكانه
غضب من المدح فيك
اول شيء انا ما معي خبر اللي عم بتقوليه
ابدا صراحه اول مره بسمعه منك ما بعتقد
ابدا حقيقه حقيقه اكثر حدا رحب بوجودي
بهالمسلسل هو استاذ عبد فهد واكثر حدا كان
عم يساعدني وعم يعطيني يعني في تناغم بيني
وبينه هو استاذ عبد فهد وحقيقه كل ما عامل
مشهد حلو عم بتلفن لي ويهنيني او يبعث لي
مسج ويقول لي انه هو فخور بشغله من اول ما
بلشت مسلسل انت هذه اللحظه فما بعتقد انه
هيدي شغله يعني اول شيء عنها بس ما بعتقد
شغله بتخصنا لانه انا وياه نحن بنعتبر
حالنا وحاكين بهالموضوع كونا اثنيناتنا
بنلعب كره قدم بنعتبر حيلنا نحنا فريق
متماسك مثل كره القدم كل واحد بيعطي
للثاني لحتى نحن الهدف يكون واحد بالاخر
هو نجاح هذا المسلسل هو بس احقاقا للحق
المخرج رجع رد كمان تحيه كبيره كبيره
لاستاذ عبد هو كمان بيقول لك احقاقا الحق
المخرج رجع رجع لعابد فهد
وعابد رجع يرد عليه قال له انه لا ابدا
انه الفرق بين المسرح والتلفزيون وما بعرف
شو انه المخرج منتبه للممثلين وما شابه
جورج ممثل من العيار الثقيل ولو فانه يعني
رجع كان عنده رد يبدو انه بحاول يكسر في
الكلام
اللي اتفسر بس هي لانه انا
جورج خلينا نتفق اتفاق لانك انت من الاول
بتقول لي استاذه استنى بتقولي استاذه
بتقول لي مدام دحين بتقول لي سيده الكريمه
عشان انا بقول لك جورج ولا اقول لك لازم
استاذ جورج كمان اوكي ساره اوكي
ساره بس تخبرك انه انا مش كثير بتابع يعني
مني كتير انتم سوشيال ميديا ما بتابع يلي
عم تقولي لي اياه جديد بالنسبه لالي بس كل
اللي بقدر اقول لك هو اذا بدك نوقف هذه
الجدليه انا واستاذ عابد فهد على صداقه
وحكيت عنه وحكيت معه عنه ببرنامج صدى
الملاعب من كل قلبي هو على طول وين ما كان
بيحكي عني منيح نحن اصدقاء وزملاء وانا
افتخر اني وقفت امام هذا العملاق في هذا
المسلسل لا هو صراحه انتم الثلاثه في هذا
المسلسل يعني مباراه خلينا نقول من الاداء
بس على سيره بتقول انك انت ما كثير داخل
في عالم السوشيال ميديا انت ما عندك
واتساب كمان يا جورج كيف عايش كيف معي
هعيش معنا على هذا الكوكب
مضبوط والله عايش عايش عم بتنفس عادي
وسعيد اكيد مروق اكيد اسعد منا من ناحيه
انك انت مروق
والله انا عايش يعني انا عايش مع الطبيعه
بحب الطبيعه كتير بحب البحر بحب الشجر
وعايش ببلتي هون بالبترون على الفيسبا
تبعي وعلى البسكليت تبعي فانا جدا سعيد
بالحياه الطبيعيه
رائع يعني انت بتعطينا مثال وبتذكرنا انه
في اسلوب مختلف للحياه السريعه اللي نحن
صرنا فيها والكلام هذا كله طيب خليني كمان
يمكن بس انقلك انه اوكي شفنا نجاح كبير في
النار بالنار شفنا نجاح كبير في براندو
الشرق او كمان كندور كوميدي شفنا نجاح
كبير في فيلم اصحاب ولا اعز فجاه حسينا
انه جورج خباز للسنين طويله كان بخيل
علينا في الاداء ومعطي نفسه كله للمسرح
ما انت شاعر بالندم انا كنت متمسك للمسرح
لانه المسرح
المسرح خليني اخبرك بس شغله انه المسرح
بياخد بياخدك كتير بيستهلكك بيستهلك يعني
في حضور ذهني وعصبي وجسدي وفكري ليلي ما
كنت قادر اعمل مسرح والتلفزيون او مسرح
ودراما مع بعض وكنت اعمل سينما من وقت
لوقت مثل فيلم تحت القصف مثل الفيلم غدي
شاركت بكتابه فيلم كفرنحوم لنديل لبكي
وكنت اعمل افلام سينما من وقت لوقت وقتها
بوقف مسرح ولكن ما كنت قادر جسديا اني
اعمل مسرح ودراما مع بعضه لما وقف المسرح
قصرا بسبب الكورونا بسبب الازمه
الاقتصاديه اللي صارت على لبنان وبطلنا
قادرين نفتح مسرح لان صار عنا ازمه تسعير
وازمه تسعير وازمه تعبير اذا بدك انا صار
عندي وقت اني اقدر اشتغل دراما وسينما
وهذا اللي صار قدرت تصور اصحاب ولا اعز
وبراندو الشرق يلي عملوا نجاح كبير وهلا
عم نحصد نجاح النار بالنار ابدا لانه بدي
اقول لك شغله خلاصه شغلي اللي عم بتشوفيها
هلا بعتقد سبب النجاح بهذه الادوار هو
تراكم خبراتي بالمسرح وصلتني اني العب
الادوار بهذه الطريقه بعتقد هيك طيب جورج
عندنا الكل جالس بيقول انه بدنا نجي كلنا
نقضي عندك ويكند نقفل فيها تليفوناتنا من
غير واتساب ونقعد معك نجرب الحياه باسلوبك
والله يا اهلا وسهلا فيكم بنروح نتصيد سمك
نحن واياكم اهلا وسهلا فيكم بتنورونا
كمان جورج انت مدرسه نحتاج نتعلم منها
كثير اشياء خارج حتى الفن انا بشكرك جدا
انتم مكسرين الدنيا في المسلسل وحديث
الناس ونكمل متابعه علشان نشوف تطور الله
يخليك شكرا لك كان معنا النجم جورج شكرا
يا ساره ورمضان كريم علينا وعليك يا رب